warum google ja ja ihr schlängelnde auch
da bin hier guck mal hier ist schon mal
meinen sixpack elf etwas klappt jetzt
bekommen beim neuen video und zwar war
ich letztens in der schule ja ich will
spaß also ich bin ja jeden tag in der
schule auf jeden fall weit in der schule
und wir waren im informatikraum und mir
war langweilig dann habe ich einfach mal
so mich selber gegoogelt also ich hab so
geguckt was gibst du alles wonach suchen
leute nach mir also wenn sie nach mir
suchen wonach suchen sie konkret oder
genau und jahren habe ich mir gedacht
hey stopp macht daraus doch einfach ein
video also ich google mich jetzt selbst
und mal gucken was da so alles kommt es
gibt wirklich lustige sachen glaube ich
ich will eigentlich gar nicht eingeladen
wenn es euch gefällt dann könnt ihr
schon mal nach oben da lassen okay
wissen gibt sie also einfach mal let's
go will ich mal sagen also leute ich es
ja früher noch anders also blockbuster
hieße ja für das wird wahrscheinlich
auch die meisten von euch und ich würde
sagen wir fangen erst mal mit dem namen
anwalt diesen namen hatte ich wirklich
lange mal gucken also ich fange jetzt
einfach mal hier ganz normal an drogbas
der blockbuster alter weg geburtstags
kommen bei alter ich würde nie mehr eine
beziehung öffentlich leben brot mag das
ist auf jeden fall korrekt allerdings
weiß ich nicht was das mit alter zu tun
hat blockbuster regel alles gute danke
danke schön ist auch schon ein bisschen
her aber warum steht
achso wegen endlich 18 ja danke schön
dort an euch beide okay das ist mir zu
langweilig also was gibt's hier noch
wiki das ist doch dieses youtube wiki
gibt es auch schon eine youtube weg da
war ich auch schon mal drauf zur suche
im youtube wiki soll ich da jetzt alex
eingeben alex wie blöd blockbuster
einmal ein treffer man versteht jetzt
ein schöner steckbrief über mich egal
ich das wenig aus der ruhe bringen wir
gucken was wir noch zu finden
hier will ich weg wir gehen jetzt
einfach mal runter bilder ja blockbuster
mein ding so wir gehen unter bilder so
was gibt es hier alles freundinnen dass
es da steht kann ich noch verstehen
alex sixpack das kommt unter alter
warum google jeder herr ja ja ihr
schlängelnde auch da bin hier guck mal
hier ist schon mal meinen sixpack
so sieht das aus ja ich hab's noch nie
gezeigt jetzt ist endlich raus das ist
mein sixpack ich finde es sehr erotisch
ich finde es sehr geil und ich pflege
meinen sixpack auch täglich wie man hier
sieht wohnort ja damit sie vor meiner
auszustehen könne was kommt ein bewohner
vermissen dass bei bilder
das werde ich jetzt mal gucken hier alle
blockbuster wohnort alex radikalsten
youtuber die geilsten youtuber kommen
echt aus bielefeld umkreis jahres stimmt
zugleich komme aus bielefeld also in der
nähe zumindest dann kann ich ja auch mal
sagen
für die die es nicht wissen steht sogar
meiner instagram bio da heißt übrigens
alex wie das ja auch langweilig also mal
gucken wie gehe es einfach mal zu meinem
aktuellen youtube nahmen über und zwar
alex und alexa monz will wie alex wie
instagram alex wie youtube alex shop ein
shop in shop wird bald von mir auch
geben mal gucken gibt schon ein stück
von mir
alexander grade ein paar shops gibt es
schon helfen kommt absolviert ihr habt
wahrscheinlich alex wie gegoogelt und
ihren shop von gene bilder ja hier bin
ich schon wieder hier bin ich schon hier
auch hier bin ich noch so an die die
wissen wollen die ich früher mal außer
sorry so war das hier das war ich früher
ich finde ich habe mich ein bisschen
fallen hat so mehr bartwuchs
meine aufgabe ist ein bisschen dunkler
geworden meine haare sind auch noch ein
bisschen dunkler geworden
früher habe ich gerne anzug getragen
heute bin ich halt mehr so zu diesem
normales teil übergegangen den halt die
ganzen youtuber tragen bis hin zu
energie dg jetzt bin ich irgendwie
wieder bei blockbuster gelandet hier
moritz sixpack ja immerhin gibt es
bilder von dir oder also ja okay bei
meinen sixpack gibt es auch bilder von
ihr habt ja gerade gesehen mal gucken
was bei moritz kommt da brauche ich ja
demnächst gar nicht mehr auf youporn
kinder kann ich auch hier
moritz gratzik hinein führte das ist nun
spaß ist nun spaß aber schicke bilder
moore ist wirklich muss ich an dieser
stelle mal sagen gefällt mir und wenn
ihr moritz nackt sehen wollt dann gibt
einfach moritz six pack 1 also nicht
ganz nackt am oberkörper weiß ja auch
immerhin schon was und wenn dieses video
sagen war 20.000 likes bekommt dann
werde ich da auch ein foto
bei google bilder mit meinen sixpack
also ihr könnt ja in die kommentare
schreiben was glaubt ihr glaubt ich habe
einen sixpack oder glaub ich hab kein
sixpack da bin ich mal gespannt
eigentlich sollte das jetzt ein spaß
sein mit dem 20.000 eigentlich könnte
man das ruhig machen das machen war
leute ich würde sagen das reicht erst
mal ihr müsst auf jeden fall noch
kräftig weiter googeln und immer coole
sachen hinzufügen damit ich hier vorn
zweite folge machen kann also geht auf
google und google google google mich
glück bügelte mich genommen welches
wieder gefallen hat dann lassen wir nach
oben da können auch keine kommentare
schreiben und jasna bislang war es
eingeblendet
ich bin jetzt gerade in österreich und
wir sehen uns am nächsten sonntag wieder
denke ich schaff da noch ein video aus
sondern wir sehen uns einmal dran was
lust mit mir hatte